for me like the hand-holding service is
more than just finding the property
which I know I'm gonna find and we've
already found one out of the first two
viewings that we've looked at but
understanding different businesses
mindsets is crucial to me in terms of my
own development
having halfway through the day had a
number of conversations I'm now looking
at not only buying one property today
but potentially three well my perception
was oK you've got a property let it out
but I never thought of HMO as a way of
going to I went on the property course
which was what February yeah and they're
now looking at it we're now end of March
looking at buying Tori properties it's
fantastic and for me the portfolio of
passive income my business is going very
well
but I'm not getting any possibly by the
violent negotiate the deal I won't make
you any money yeah and yeah it's going
successful in his doom world doing big
numbers in terms of printer sales but
I've got a ten month old and for me it's
like okay over a period of time can we
get this to twenty twenty-five thirty
forty property like assignments that I
probably get addicted to it I probably
will do because it's like a light bulb
switch done yeah remark it was like why
didn't I think of that before
and so now yeah and that's only gonna
come through conversation and that's why
I was very keen to use the hand-holding
service because it's like yeah you're
having the hand-holding so it's more
than just finding a house it's through
those relationship that bill and the
team what makes everything happening if
you've got a strong team I can be sure
that once I've got my HMO yeah it's
gonna be kicked out and I'm not going to
be happy to be doing leg work which will
take my time away from my family but
also other business interests that I
have and that's that's crucial to me
in terms of this is a vehicle to
financial freedom for me so
Kyle what's going on buddy
yeah Batman how long I did I did I did
it was great
not really Mike Jamie the family missing
the fact that every child right I think
I've got you another sale buddy all
right that probably would crush yes
bring field roads
spoke to the lady lovely lovely it's on
494 500 we've crunched down numbers now
she said to me on the day she said that
she she would accept 90 now we've
crunched some numbers together we can
actually pay a little bit more than that
so I can't imagine that's gonna not go
throat we can pay ninety thousand four
hundred and fifty pounds that's what's
gonna come through the calculation
that's that's great so I just thought if
you could formally put that forward for
us give her a shout this one's gonna be
a god called Aaron Thomas yeah I know
he's got his proof a deposit it's got
his mortgage all lined up and these et
this one wants to be the first of many
so we might have a few more sales away I
got you I got your email I'll give you a
call back about that I did I did thanks
man appreciate that before it hits the
market that's great all right make that
be amazing just call me back as soon as
you as soon as you get as soon as you
get the earth fantastic thank you my
friends feature so shares car you
tonight come on we've we've got there's
a property Wolverhampton
that's accepted at offer which is
fantastic news and there's the potential
also to get another one
yeah because the chunk of it is right
I'd even think about it too that's what
good news yay fantastic what I'll do
then is if I just drop your email with
Aaron's address details and all the
usual stuff and then we'll get the ball
ball let's go drop Cheers thanks Samuel
I've got to call him the man that can
we've been and viewed six properties
today we've got an offer accepted on a
Wolverhampton property HMO 4-letter
ballrooms excited it's my first property
on the property market outside of my
residential mortgage and family home and
I'm looking forward to moving forward
and possibly in another one today and
what solve returning that's what are you
talking we're looking at a minimum of
between forty to fifty percent return on
investment excellent I call us rather
than high five man